ROBERT KUBIS: You
might remember me
from two of the keynote demos
that I've done this morning.
My job is Cloud
Developer Advocate.
So what we understand
of the title
is basically either
a software developer
with a license to speak.
Or, how I'd like to
introduce myself,
as like the bidirectional
channel of you,
developers that build
on our platform,
to the developers inside Google
that build this platform.
So please feel free
to reach out to us.
To me personally, you can
reach out on Twitter, to me
under the name hostirosti.
And we would like
to hear your stories
like how you use Google
Cloud Platform, where
you think it's complicated,
and where we could do better.
Only with your feedback we can
actually improve our products.
Now, today I'm going to talk
a bit about Cloud Spanner--
on the one hand about the
history of Cloud Spanner, how
we got about it in Google.
I will provide
some explanations,
what Cloud Spanner is.
I also go down to some
architectural level
and talk about the
technologies and the hardware
that we use to actually
make that possible, what we
can achieve with Cloud Spanner.
And at the end, I'm
going to do some coding
and show you a demo.
Now, I'm going to talk
about Cloud Spanner
and look at the history of it.
We have to go back
around 12 years to 2005.
Now, Google at that
point has been around
for a couple of years, and our
business was growing massively.
So we had our AdWords system
on the back of a sharded MySQL.
System.
Now, this MySQL system was
sharded on the customer ID,
and we had to reshard
the system several times.
The last time we
resharded the system
it took actually several years.
And this was not a solution
that we could go forward.
With the way that
we were growing,
this was not a
sustainable solution.
So we needed something
that can scale to the point
that we needed it.
So we needed something
that horizontally scales.
We had a lot of customers.
We were growing quickly.
We needed a system which
is still strong consistent
and has the relational
database attributes
like the asset transactions.
So we were dealing with money.
We were dealing with budgets.
We had customers.
We had partners.
We had agencies.
So eventual consistency
was not an option for us.
Now, also, every minute the
system was down, we and also
our customers were losing money.
So we couldn't accept any
downtime for the system.
We need a system where
we can make changes,
where we can make updates, where
we can make security patches
without any incurred downtime.
So prior to Spanner,
there was no system
that could provide
all these qualities,
and that's the reason
we built it ourselves.
Now, if we look at
Cloud Spanner compared
to what we have internally,
you get the same system,
the same performance,
the same consistency
as the internal Spanner
that we are using.
So its the same site
reliability engineers
that are watching
our systems that
also watching your systems.
Now, as mentioned already,
we needed asset transactions.
We needed global consistency.
We actually have the highest
standard of the consistency.
Our consistency model
is external [INAUDIBLE]
Now, one important
part was also that we
wanted to tap into the
knowledge and the experience
of our developers.
We didn't want to put
a system in their hands
which is completely
different to what they
have been dealing with all their
developer time or developer
life.
So for us, it was
really important
that certain
semantics are the same
as you would think of them in a
traditional relational database
system.
On top of this, we added things
like automatic and synchronous
replication so we can
span multiple regions
and we can actually span
globally in Spanner.
And for a regional
system, that means
that we provide an SLA of
four nines of availability.
So this is about four minutes
and 38 seconds of downtime
that we allow per month.
Now, for our
multiregional setups,
where you span your database
over multiple regions--
and I will talk a little
bit about what that means--
we actually provide an SLA with
five nines of availability,
which boils down
to about 26 seconds
of allowed downtime per month.
Another really
important aspect for us
when we were building Cloud
Spanner was to make it open,
to enable customers and
developers to adopt it easily.
So when we started
and when we were
working with our
early-access customers,
we were focusing on making it
as easy as possible to adopt it.
So some of these things, we
were using standard SQL NZ 2011.
We actually use this across
most of our products, database
products, within Google.
We added things like
enterprise features,
like encryption, audit locking,
identity access management,
things like that.
We spent quite some time
and invested some resources
in building our client
libraries in major languages,
and there are more and more
of these language libraries
coming up with how to
connect automatically
to the Cloud Spanner.
And currently in a
read-only version,
we also have a GDPC driver
for Cloud Spanner, where
you can connect your most
favorite like the iTools
directly to Spanner
and use them.
One of the things that we
always get asked or compared to
is, on the one hand, the
traditional relational database
system, and on the
other hand the NoSQL,
horizontally-scalable
data systems.
And as you see here, we put
up a small matrix of features
that we are comparing here.
So if you look at
a traditional RDBMS
and you outscale this
system, usually what
are you going to do is you build
a master replica system where
you have your master--
like a MySQL master--
and then you have a
failover instance,
and you might have some
read-through replicas
to free up your master
of read capacity
to have more write
capacity on your master.
Now, if you want to do any
kind of maintenance on this,
usually what you have to do is
to failover to your failover
instance if you do maintenance
on your master-- for instance,
security patches or an
update of the version.
Now, that incurs downtime
and loses you money,
and it's quite some operational
risk that you incur there.
On the other hand, if you look
at like the NoSQL systems,
if you basically [INAUDIBLE]
traditional RDBMS,
many went through
NoSQL, and we're
looking at things like Cassandra
or other database systems that
are out there in
the NoSQL space.
But what that meant
is, basically, yes, you
do have tunable
consistency, but most
of the times what we actually
do to get consistency,
what still is required
in many businesses,
is that you build this
consistency and transaction
logic in your application layer.
So you pull up this logic
into your application layer,
and that makes it quite complex
and difficult and risky.
So with Cloud
Spanner, you basically
can move this logic
back into the database,
and you still have
these qualities
of a traditional database
system of asset transactions
with the scalability
of a NoSQL system.
So a typical workload that
we are seeing, especially
with early-access
program members,
can be put in like
four categories.
The first one is, if you have
a transactional system, things
like inventory management
or financial transactions
or something like
that, and you basically
share outgrow the size what
your traditional database
system can handle.
Then, that is where
Spanner can come in.
You still have the
need of transactions,
but your traditional
systems can't handle
the size of the database.
And Spanner can do this for you.
With the horizontal scalability,
we can also scale the data size
or the database size. .
One of the things that we get
asked often is also, well,
is Cloud Spanner only
for big databases?
And I have to say no.
Even if you have small databases
which are a couple of gigabytes
big but you have a lot of
traffic on this database
and you outscale your
solutions in terms of read
and write transactions
that you can run,
that is another use
case for Cloud Spanner
if you need to scale, read,
and write transactions.
Another thing is if you have
mission critical applications.
So you really need a database
system that is available
four nines or five
nines, and you just
can make any sacrifice on this.
Again, that is something
where Cloud Spanner
comes into the plane.
The way that we architect it
enables this high availability
and disaster recovery, and it
enables you to basically build
a global data plane
where you can have,
for instance, if you think of
supply chain management system,
and you want to really know
like what items are still
in your storage and
which items you have sold
and things like that, you want
to be as accurate as possible.
And you want to have
a view on your data
as recent as possible.
And the fourth is if you
think of systems where you
traditionally ETL data around.
So for instance,
you have a user base
in a MySQL, Postgres
database and then
you have some logged data or
some audit data in a Cassandra
cluster.
And then, at the
end of the day, you
ETL that into another system
and do some analytics on this.
Now, this is again also a
use case for Cloud Spanner.
Since we can scale on read and
write as well as on storage,
you can combine and have these
data co-located in one database
and do all the analytics there.
So to talk a bit about more
of the architecture of Cloud
Spanner, I want to synchronize
on the terminology, so to say.
And everything in Cloud Spanner
starts with an instance.
So the instance
is basically where
you would define
how many nodes you
want to have for your
instance, so what's
the horizontal scale
of your instance
and the capacity of storage.
Now, in this instance, you can
create a bunch of databases.
Currently, the limit is set
to 100 databases per instance.
And then, in these databases,
you can create tables.
Currently, per database, you
can create about 2,048 tables.
Now, this is basically
what you see as a developer
and as a user.
To enable us to
distribute your data
and to distribute and
scale on reads and writes,
we have another
concept underneath,
which is the internal
concept, which we call split.
Now, what is a split?
A spit is basically if
you look at as a table
and you have your primary
key, we divide this table.
And we divide that
based lexicographically
on the primary key,
or you could say also
alphanumeric numeric
ordering or alphabetical
ordering basically.
And we basically use
ranges and assign
these splits to work on nodes.
Now, how does that look like?
So if you look at an instance
view of a Spanner instance,
you have in a regional
instance a distribution
over three zones.
So we have our compute on
the top as you can see.
One Spanner node means you have
one compute node in each zone
for a regional instance.
So for regional, that means
you have three compute nodes
in three zones.
And then, you have storage
in all of those that
can be used by these nodes.
So now if you want to
distribute the reads and writes,
you basically take these
splits and assign these splits
to a set of nodes across
these three zones.
But, I mentioned earlier that
we are globally consistent.
So one of the criteria here
that is really, really important
is that there's never more
than one group of nodes
responsible for a
split, and we actually
need one member
in this group who
is the one, the
leader of this group.
And what we are using to do
this is, on the one hand, Paxos.
So the Paxos algorithm
basically allows
us to vote for a leader
with a majority voting.
And we need another
thing to make sure
that we have exactly one Paxos
[INAUDIBLE] and exactly one
leader for any split.
And what we use there
is something that we
invented and called TrueTime.
Now, what is TrueTime?
If you synchronize your
watches with your neighbor
and you go away and you
come back together in a week
and you look at your watches,
it's very highly likely
that your watches have drifted.
So they drift because
of cosmic rays.
They drift because of
different temperatures
that you have been.
There are many factors that
let your watches drift.
Now, to ensure for us that
we have exactly one leader,
we basically need something that
is close to a global wall clock
time.
And I mentioned Spanner is
distributed across the globe,
so we need something where
we can synchronize time
across the globe.
Now, it's not possible as I just
mentioned to just use a watch,
synchronize it in one place, and
goes somewhere and distribute
these watches to all
our data centers.
They will drift away and they
are not synchronized anymore,
and then basically
what could happen
is that you have two leaders
for the same split, which
means your data can
become inconsistent.
So what we needed is,
basically, we needed something
to quantify the drift that
we have between these data
centers, and we
needed a technology
to synchronize all these
watches in our data center.
So what TrueTime
does, actually it
doesn't give you
a specific time.
TrueTime gives you an interval.
So you have a lower
bound and an upper bound.
Now, the lower bound of
your TrueTime timestamps
is a timestamp where you
know that this timestamp has
passed all over the world.
Through this timestamp that
you get as a lower bound has
passed, you know that for sure.
Now, the upper
bound that you get
is a timestamp that has
passed nowhere in the world,
and you can be sure
that this is the case.
Now, we use this to
select the leaders
and make sure that we have
exactly one leader and one
Paxos group for a split.
And by that, we can ensure that
we have global consistency.
Now, how does it
look in hardware?
In all our data centers, we have
atomic clocks and GPS receivers
or time clocks, so to say.
And we use GPS to synchronize
the clocks around the globe.
And then, we have atomic
clocks, which we synchronize
with these GPS time masters.
And every time we ask for a
TrueTime timestamp or interval,
we use a subset of
our time masters
that are available
in our data center.
And then we get it back.
And if there's any
outlier, we basically
can say, OK, this
atomic clock is bad.
We don't care
about this anymore,
and we use the ones that
are looking more reasonable.
Now, we synchronize
these clocks--
we describe it in our paper--
like roughly every 30 seconds.
And as you can see
there, the clock drift
is about 200
microseconds per second.
So the interval that
you can get down
to like single digits, very low
single digits, milliseconds.
So that basically means,
all over the world,
we can get an interval where
we know the lower timestamp
and the upper timestamp
are not further away
than two milliseconds or
maybe one millisecond.
And we know that the lower
bound has passed everywhere
and the upper bound
has passed nowhere.
And that enables us to do
this global consistency.
Now, some of you might
ask what happened
if all my atomic clocks
fail in the data center
or all my time masters
fail in the data center.
Now, we can still get these
true timestamps or timestamp
intervals from a
different data center.
And we calculate the
time of the transmission
and things like that.
What basically means, this
interval becomes bigger.
Maybe this interval is
then 10 milliseconds or 100
milliseconds, which basically
means, yes, our database
system is slowing down,
but it's not stopping.
We can still operate.
We just slow down a bit.
And that, I think,
is pretty amazing.
Now, let's look at a
more practical example,
and I'd like to explain that
based on a life of a query.
So in this case, I am
selecting all events where
the name is Cloud Summit Paris.
So think of the agenda
that we get back for this.
Now, the client sends a request.
And in our case here, it comes
in through one of our followers
in this Paxos group.
So we have a leader in zone
two, and we have two followers
in zone three and zone one.
Now, the request comes
in through the follower
in zone one, and that one
will basically ask the leader
and say, hey, do I have
the most recent data?
I am seeing this timestamp of
the data that is requested.
Is this the latest
timestamp that you have?
Now, if the leader says
yep, you're current,
I can just serve that data
from a follower and I'm done.
Now, in the case that my request
comes in and my followers--
or my replica, in this case--
doesn't have the
data, the leader
will respond and
say no, you don't
have the most current data.
But just wait.
The data is already in flight.
So just wait out that
time till you have
this timestamp of your data.
And once you see
that timestamp, you
can serve the data
because then you'd
know for sure that you
have the most current data.
So I basically just
wait, and then I
send the response to my client.
Now, another really
powerful feature in Spanner
is that you can do
consistent stale reads.
Now, what does that mean?
A consistent stale
read basically
means that you
provide a boundary
or you provide a specific
timestamp within seven days
where you say, I want to see
the state of the database
on that specific
timestamp, or I want
to see the state of the database
and I don't care if it's up to,
let's say, 15 seconds old.
So basically, in this
case, I'm sending a request
from my client.
It comes in again through
one of the replicas.
And I say, it's fine if
this data is 15 seconds old.
In most of the cases--
like, in most, most,
most, most of the cases--
this data will be
already at the replica,
and they will have a timestamp
where they know, OK, they
can serve this data which is
within this boundary of 15
seconds staleness.
And they can just
respond to the client.
We don't have to ask
the leader or anything.
And this is especially
powerful if you
have a Cloud Spanner instance
that is globally distributed.
That is, you have, let's say,
a read-write master set up
or read-write quorum
in the US, and then you
have read-through replicas
in Europe and in Asia.
Now, if you have Asian
clients coming in
and they don't care if they
have the most current data
but they want to have a
consistent state of data,
they can be served with data
immediately from the read
replicas in Asia
without consulting
the read-write quorum in the US.
And that speeds up your
queries quite a bit.
Now, if we look at the
read-write transaction,
you can imagine in a
read-write transaction
I need the leader involved.
I'm changing the state.
And I'm globally
consistent, so I
need the leader to be involved.
So in this case, we are
routing the request directly
to the leader of the Paxos
groups that are involved.
So if multiple Paxos
groups are involved,
we use two-phase commit
to basically communicate
and synchronize between them.
If a single Paxos
group is involved,
we basically can just
do the transaction
within this Paxos group.
Now, in my example here,
I want to update my talk
as you can see here.
So the first thing that
I do is I do a read.
I get my query result and
already acquiring some logs.
And then I'm doing some changes.
I'm writing this
mutation to a buffer,
and then I'm committing
this transaction.
And the leader
basically in that time
sends out the write
requests of this new data
to the followers, the replicas.
And as soon as a quorum, so the
majority of that Paxos group,
responds with yes, I
have written that data,
we can respond to
the client and say
your transaction
has been successful
and we can release the locks.
Now, as for the data
format or the layout, what
we have in Spanner
is pretty much
what you're used to from a
traditional database system.
So we have tables with columns
that are strongly typed.
As you can see
here, as an example
I have a singers table
and an albums table and I
want to join them--
for instance, by
the primary key.
In this case, I'm using the
singer ID as an example.
Now, in traditional
database systems,
you have something like
a foreign key constraint
where it can say, OK,
if I delete a singer,
I want to have all my
albums deleted as well.
Now, in a distributed
system, this
becomes really complicated
and very harmful,
so we don't support
this semantic.
But we support a little bit
like a foreign key constraint
minus minus semantic.
So in case you have something
where you have tables
that you join a
lot and where you
want to be sure that this data
in these tables is co-located,
we have a construct that is
called interleaved tables.
So in interleaved tables,
what happens is basically
you interleave your child
table into a parent table
based on the primary key.
So the child table
has to basically
be precluded with the primary
key of the parent table.
And then we basically can
interleave this data right
where the parent
rows are living.
So basically, what happens is
they end up in the same split.
And as you know, the split is
managed by one Paxos group,
so we don't have to go to
different compute nodes
and get all the
data together if we
do this [INAUDIBLE] every time.
Now, you have to be a
bit careful about this.
Don't overuse interleaving
because, as just mentioned,
it all ends up in one split.
So you can run into
things like hotspotting
or you can exhaust actually
the storage limits of a split.
So you have to be a
bit careful there.
Now, what does it look like in
SQL or in the DDL statement?
You basically just add like
the interleave in [? zingers ?]
or the interleave
in the parent table,
and then you can actually
have multiple levels
of this interleaving
if you need to.
Another powerful feature
that I mentioned earlier
is online schema updates.
So if you want to
evolve your application
and you want to add columns
or things like that,
you can do that while all
your load is going on.
And it is done in a transaction.
So they are transactionally
consistent if you
do a schema update.
For instance, here, if I'm
changing my singers table
and add a column H, I can do
that inside a transaction.
So there a couple of schema
design don'ts which are coming
from the nature of this
being a distributed,
horizontal-scalable database.
So if you come from a
MySQL or Postgres world,
this is not a lift and
shift that you can do.
You can't take your
application that you
have built on top of MySQL or
Postgres and just move it over.
You have to do some redesigning
and some changes on your schema
in most of the cases.
So one of the things that
are really harmful in Spanner
are things like an outer
increment in Tetra.
So think of outer
increment feature in MySQL
where every time I
insert a row it gets
automatically assigned a new ID.
Now, if we have like these, we
have monotonically increasing
numbers.
And as I mentioned earlier,
we are doing splits
by alphabetically-sorted
ranges or lexicographic ranges.
Now, you can imagine, if you
have a monotonically increasing
ID or timestamps, for instance,
every time you insert data
it basically gets inserted
into your last split.
And your hotspotting
on your last split.
Even though you might have a
thousand splits for your table
and you always insert row with
the most current timestamp,
you're basically sending all
this data to the last split.
And by that, you
restrict your scalability
and you hotspot on that split.
Again, also, with
interleaving, the same problem.
If you interleave a lot
of data into one row,
into one parent row, you
interleave all this data
into one split.
And again, you can
also cause hotspotting.
So be careful of how deep
you go and how much data
you interleave into
a parent table.
So just to give an example,
this is a little bit more
graphically here.
If you have at timestamp
as a primary key,
like a last access
timestamp for instance,
and then user ID and some other
data for each of your rows,
since it's
lexicographically ordered,
you get all these
into one split.
So what can you do to
avoid this hotspotting?
So one of the things that
you can do is using UIDs--
and they are preferable
Version 4 or later--
as your primary keys.
You can do things like you add
a charting counter or charting
ID to your data in front.
You had a charting idea to your
timestamp and things like that.
So as an example here,
again, same table
as we saw before, we have
our last access timestamp,
we have our user ID, and we
just add in front of it a
sharding ID.
And by adding this sharding
ID, now we can actually
distribute the load
off inserts or updates
on these rows across
multiple splits
and you're not
hotspotting on a split.
So with this, I hope
you got some insights
on how Cloud Spanner
works under the hood
and what things to
pay attention to.
And now, I want to
show a little bit demo
and I want to show a
little bit how you can
get started with Cloud Spanner.
So please switch
to the demo laptop.
OK.
Perfect.
So your first stop
is Cloud Spanner,
or cloud.google.com/spanner,
which is basically
your entrance page into Cloud
Spanner and has a multitude
of information
linked from there.
I want to point out a couple
of things, or actually
one thing down here.
There have been a
couple of case studies
with our early-access
members for Cloud Spanner,
and one of them is Quizlet
that moved from a sharded MySQL
system to Cloud Spanner.
And they talk in very
technical and very
detailed about their transition
from sharded MySQL system
to Cloud Spanner.
So if you are in the
situation that you
will have a sharded
system and you
want to explore
Cloud Spanner, this
is a good start to look
into what are the things
to pay attention to.
Another thing that we
sometimes get asked is,
does Cloud Spanner
defeat the CAP theory?
Now, if you look at
distributed systems
and you know Eric Brewer, he
came up with this CAP theory
where you have to
basically choose two out
of three of consistency,
availability, and partitioning.
So you can't have a consistent
available system that is also
partitioned, things like that.
And now, I'm asked, OK,
does Spanner actually
defeat the CAP theory?
And the answer is no.
If Cloud Spanner becomes
partitioned to the thing
that we don't have a majority
anymore for our Paxos groups,
we default to a consistent
system and become unavailable.
But the likelihood is
very, very, very low.
Otherwise, we wouldn't
give an SLA of four nines
for regional, five
nines for multiregional.
Because of the system
and the hardware that we
have underneath and the way
the Spanner was architectured,
this likelihood
of a split brain,
how it's called sometimes,
is very, very low.
Now, another thing that
I want to point out is,
if you look into building a
new application or migrating
an application, please read
our white papers that we have
linked in the documentation
which talks a lot about
do's and don'ts in terms of
schema design and creative
design.
There are some specifics
to Cloud Spanner
to get the most
out of it, and we
want to enable you to
get the most out of it.
So for the ones that have seen
the keynote demo this morning,
you already know how to
create a Spanner instance.
I just want to show that
really quickly again.
This is basically
the home screen
if you've created a project
in the Cloud console.
So let me actually pump
this up a little bit.
So if you want to
go to Spanner, you
have multiple options
to go to Spanner.
You either can use the hamburger
symbol here on the left
and look for Cloud Spanner.
You can type into this
field appear, in the search.
Or if you're a VIM user, you
know how to search on VIM.
Basically, use slash,
and it automatically
focuses into the
search box, and then
you can do Spanner and click
on it and you're at Spanner.
Now, to create an
instance, I just
click on Create an Instance.
I name it.
I'll select Configuration.
That's through Europe.
And I say like five
nodes, and I create.
And as seen in the architectural
overview that I've shown--
oh, I have no sufficient quota.
Let's do one, and fingers
crossed that it works.
So as we've seen in the
architectural diagram,
we are actually
distributing and separating
the compute and
storage to enable
the horizontal scalability.
Now, to create a database,
we do the same thing.
I say I want to have
a demo database.
I can use our dialogs
to create a schema.
For instance, if I want
to have a singers table,
I create a singers table.
I'm adding a column--
for instance H.
I have to select the primary
key, and then I click Create.
And again, within a
couple of seconds,
you have your database.
Now, just to show you,
if I want to edit this,
I can do an edit schema.
Again, I can use
DDL or our dialog.
And I can say, for instance,
city [INAUDIBLE] string.
And this is done, and then save.
And as you will see
in a second, there's
a box coming up which shows
that this is basically
running in a transaction
to schema update.
So as soon as this
transaction has finished,
the new schema
will be available.
Now, I want to switch a little
bit to more complex schema.
And again, you might remember
that one from the keynote demo.
I basically have the
scenario of a ticket broker
where you have event organizers
who want to sell tickets,
and then you have customers or
fans that want to buy tickets.
And I just came up with
a sample application
to represent such a system.
Now, what you have in
this is, on one hand,
for instance, if
you want to have
tours, like Bruce Springsteen
tour, Sting tour, or whatever--
Coldplay-- you
have a multi-event,
which includes basically
multiple events
in different cities.
Then you have the events.
For each event, we need a venue.
So you see a venue
up there as well.
And then, each of these
venues has different seating
categories and configuration.
So you can, for instance,
have general admission.
You can have premium seating.
You can have VIP.
And all these have
different prices assigned.
So it gets, if you think about
it, complex quite quickly.
Now, I did one thing here.
As you can see, I interleaved
the seating category actually
into the venue.
Because I'm doing this
drawing very often,
so I wanted to have the
seating category co-located
with my venue.
So I used the
interleaving in this case.
All the other things are
basically standalone tables,
and I can join them
by IDs as I wish.
So the first thing
that I want to do is--
and then in my case
here, I'm using Java--
is to show you how to
get started with Java
and connecting
against Cloud Spanner.
Now, just to check, how
many Java developers
do we have here in the room?
OK.
How many Go developers?
All right.
So you are the cool
kids on the block.
Python?
Oh, wow.
I should have done
a Python demo.
All Right, next time.
So in this case, I hope you bear
with me, Python and Go folks.
Hopefully you can
read my Java code.
So the first thing
that we want to do
is we want to authenticate.
Now, if you run this
on your local machine
and have that set up
with the G Cloud SDK
or you run it on any of our GCE
instances or inside Kubernetes,
you get a default authentication
context on these machines.
And you can just use this.
So this is really easy.
I'm just saying
Google credentials
that get application default
and I'm authenticated.
So I think this is amazing.
Just imagine what you would have
to do with all kinds of things
of keys and OAuths.
Yeah, it gets messy,
and I wouldn't
be able to do this in the
time that I have left.
Now, in case you need to
authenticate with a key,
we also have the possibility
that you create a JSON
key like a service
account, and then
you use that to authenticate
against Cloud Spanner.
Now, the next thing is
I need a client start.
So I need to say which
instance am I talking to,
which database am I talking to,
and use all this information.
The project ID and
things like that come
from these
authentication contexts.
And then, I create
a database client.
So as you can see here,
I'm creating my client.
Next thing, what I want
to do is, in this case,
a read-only transaction.
So a read-only transaction,
the advantage of this
is I don't need to
acquire any logs.
So I can just do this.
We don't need protection.
And basically, what
you do is DB line
dot single use for your
read-only transaction
in our case.
And then, I want to,
of course, run a query.
So here, in this
case, I am looking
for all my monthly events that
are happening from right now
till tomorrow, so
24 hours later.
So as you can see here, I'm
using a statement builder,
and I can put
parameter placeholders
and then bind these parameters
down here as you can see.
So I'm using, basically,
for the date timestamp now,
and then for the next day I
am creating a new timestamp
where I'm adding 24 hours.
And last but not
least, I, of course,
want to show this and iterate
through my result set.
So I basically just, as
we know from iterable,
we just iterate
through the list.
We don't have any
results that's left.
And I can point to the
results in from my query
either by locations or ID.
Like you can see, getString
I0, which basically means
I want to have the first
position of my query,
or you can also use the
column names if you use them.
So I could use, basically,
multi-event ID, for instance,
to get the value of this for
this row for this column.
And then I can run all this.
And fingers crossed,
it hopefully works.
So see, I also limited
it to 10 results.
So we see that it runs.
Now, this took a
little bit, and that
is because creating the
connection to Cloud Spanner
takes a little bit of time.
If I would run it multiple times
with the connection standing,
it gets much, much faster.
So you get to single-digit
query response times actually.
Now, I mentioned that we can
do is stale consistent reads.
And what I can do
is I just modify
my single read-only transaction,
and I'm adding a time bound.
So as you can see up there, I
am adding at timestamp bound off
a max staleness of 15 seconds.
And by that,
basically, if I come
in through a follower
or a replica,
the replica can respond
with the data right away.
So we can just run
this again, and you
will see that you get
some data back as well.
Now, the next thing
that I want to show
is a read-only transaction.
Now, I have all this
stuff here already,
so this is just a repetition.
So I'm going to jump right
away to the insert transaction.
Now, what I do here is a
write-only transaction.
And first of all, what I
have to create is a mutation.
So we don't have currently DML.
You can't do insert into
and things like that.
But you can use the
client libraries,
and they have an automatic
way of inserting data.
Now, there's something that we
use that's called mutations,
and I want to elaborate
a little bit on this.
In Spanner, a mutation is
basically a change of a cell,
like a modification of a cell.
So that means if you have
a table with five columns
and you insert a row,
you have five mutations.
Now, why do I mention that?
The thing is, for
transaction, we
have a limit of 20,000
mutations per transaction.
And you have to be aware of
this if you are adding indexes
on your table.
For instance, we have
our five-column table
and we add an index
with three columns
where we do an index on
three of the five columns.
Then we basically have, for each
row that we add in our table,
we have eight mutations,
five for the table
and three for the index.
And it's really,
really important
to remember if you ever see
that error exceeding mutations
limit, that you think
OK, a mutation is not
one row, one mutation.
A mutation is one row multiplied
by columns and so on and so on.
So in this case, I'm
creating an account.
I'm adding my name, email
address and everything.
And then I run this.
There's one thing that
I want to mention.
Basically Here, you see I'm
basically doing DBClient.write
and I provide these mutations.
And I am just writing that.
So this will return
me the timestamp
when this has been written.
Now, we have this
in the database,
and I can show
that really quick.
I have here my demo
instance, and I'm
going to go to the accounts.
And if you go to
Data, we're going
to see here my data
that's just got inserted.
Now, one of the things
that I want to do is,
if I want to do a read-write, so
I have to create a transaction
context in my client,
and then do the read,
which I can do either through
the read API or I can use SQL--
so in this case, I'm
creating this read here--
and then my mutation.
But there's something
special about this construct.
As you can see here, we do
this read-write transaction
and we provide a transaction
runner, transaction callable.
Now, why are we doing this?
As you can see
here, we basically
provide the client
library complete
function of this transaction.
And that enables us
from the client side
to rerun your transaction
in case it fails.
So you basically
provide us all of what
has to be done in
this transaction,
and we can rerun it
on the client side
if there should be any
problems with this.
So again, if we run this,
I'm just basically selecting
my account and I'm changing
my name from Robert
to Spanner Guru.
So if we go back here and go to
our account table, to my data,
we now see that my
name has changed.
And then, I could do this
also programmatically,
but we just recently added this
feature in our Cloud Console
that you can now also edit
data right here or delete it.
In my case, I want to
clean up after myself,
so I delete this data.
Let's switch back to the slides.
So with one minute
left, I just want
to mention briefly
the other database
products that we have in our
Cloud Platform portfolio.
So our database products
range from in-memory databases
to the data warehouse databases.
So if you, for instance,
build an App Engine,
you can use our App
Engine Memcache.
If you look at a relational, we
have managed database servers
where you can have MySQL
or Postgres as a managed
solution, which can be
set up with failover
and read replicas.
But that is a
vertical-scalable solution.
Now, if you need
horizontal-scalable solutions
for the criteria that I
mentioned throughout this talk,
you are looking
at Cloud Spanner.
If you look at more of
the NoSQL databases,
on the one hand Cloud
Datastore, which
is more like a document store.
And then we have
Cloud Bigtable, which
has key values which can
have immense throughput
and scale with your needs
on the throughput side
and also on the
query side in terms
of single-digit
query response times
even if you have terabytes
of data in your database.
Now, Cloud Datastore
supports you
from small applications
up to huge applications.
Just think, Snapchat built
their entire application
on Datastore and App Engine.
And then, if you look more
onto object solutions,
you can look into
Cloud Storage where
you can save basically
blobs, like video files.
The nice thing
about cloud storage
is also it's backed
by Spanner again.
And it enables you to,
if you store a file
and you look
anywhere in the world
on the state of what kind of
files you have in your buckets,
you will see a consistent
state across the globe.
So if your data is there, you
will see it from everywhere.
And that's enabled
by Cloud Spanner.
Now, if you want
to do analytics,
we have a Cloud-native
solution, fully-managed solution
called BigQuery, and
BigQuery is amazing to crunch
through terabytes
even petabytes of data
in seconds or very low minutes.
So if you're looking at
lowering your costs of ownership
in doing analytics, BigQuery
is one of your things
where you should look into.
With this, thank you very much.
I hope you enjoyed this talk,
and enjoy the rest of the day.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]